I think as a family we we really wanted
people to get to know my dad right I
wanted people to know him the way he
really was and the way I knew him and
and I think he's been mischaracterized
over the years he's been called
reclusive and and other things and it's
just not true and and I just want people
you know desperately want people to know
that and you use a lot of the film then
the super 8 film that was yes family
footage people haven't seen before yeah
in fact I you know I don't even recall
seeing it myself so does it help jog
your memory about what it was like
growing up with Neil Armstrong I mean
you remember me we see some of the some
of the footage there and you know it's a
it's a snip of what must you know I've
been playing with you and your brother
and sure and interacting you know I have
a lifetime of memories from from that
time as well but it's always nice to go
back and and see things that you've
forgotten so this film is really showing
the way the way my dad was and the way
we were as a family but you do also get
that other side the tension between him
and your mother about well leveling with
you guys with the boys about the mission
and telling the mum be telling you about
the dangers I can't fault him because he
had a lot on his mind really you know he
they were preparing for the mission I'm
sure they're thinking about all the
things that might happen and and kind of
processing and trying to prepare I think
we're I in his shoes I I would I would
just be thinking how do I rely on my
training how do I make sure that I do
everything that I'm supposed to do in
the way that I'm supposed to do it so
that the mission goes successfully tell
me what it was like to watch your dad be
the first to walk on the moon on live
television well you know at the time as
a six-year-old I was excited but I was
unaware of the of the danger right I
didn't really realize all the things
that could go wrong that that didn't
really occur to me until until 1986 when
when the Challenger tragedy happened but
your dad took danger in his stride in he
it was uncanny how even he could stay
you know that was a big part of the
training of all these of
these astronauts that they'd been test
pilots their job was to react when
things went wrong and then to go back
and report to the engineers that were
building these devices you know now they
can do all that electronically let's
talk more about the man and how he dealt
with without Fame when he returned when
did he realize that he'd become amongst
if not the most famous man in the world
I would guess the world to her and you
know great for NASA to have organized
such a thing to use to go to all these
countries share the learning share the
experiences and try to use that as a
platform to build bridges between
nations but that was the thing about
your father wasn't it that he didn't use
it for his personal gain okay there was
some commercial deals but really at the
margins I mean some astronauts went into
politics one imagines he could almost
have run for the presidency with that
kind of Fame but that wasn't that wasn't
the kind of guy he was
he was not a not really a political
person he didn't want a lot of attention
but he was an engineer and he loved
aircraft design from from a nine ten
year old boy he wanted to be an aircraft
designer he and in fact he only became a
pilot so that he could be an Air a
better aircraft designer right that's
what he wanted and so when he had his
choice of anything to do after he
retired from NASA he he turned to he
became a professor of Aeronautics but he
didn't become a recluse I mean that's
also the kind of ya know host moon
picture of it and you see that in this
film that's what's so wonderful about it
he's always smiling is always laughing
he's always enjoying himself with other
people those aren't the characteristics
of a recluse right but I mean is it
partly in contrast with Buzz Aldrin I
mean how did he get on with boss you
know there were tales of of tensions
between them they got along well yeah
but they didn't know each other they
hadn't spent a lot of time on past
missions as a lot of the crews had they
respected one another and and they they
knew that they each had important
strengths to bring to the mission what
about for you then those years then
going through school how many times did
here one small step for man not as often
as you think ya know
you know talking about my father talking
about you know that celebrity was it was
just not something that was was
ingrained in me I in fact it was quite
the opposite you know stay stay humble
work hard and be respectful and you know
you inherited those traits well yeah I
inherited or or or was not them yeah so
so that's the way it was in school so
you know people say tell me about you
know take your dad to work day that
didn't happen do you think there ever
will be a return to the do yeah but I
don't think we've progressed as as far
as we'd hoped and and I think even that
even the folks that served on the
shuttle would would say the same but I
really feel like now we're poised to
take that to start that next generation
if you will of exploration and and the
the fiftieth anniversary I think is a
nice launch vehicle for that what if
somebody came along and said to you hey
Mark son of Neil 50th anniversary you're
a fit guy we can train you up let's put
you back on the moon yes 100%
particularly if I can take my whole
family with me let's let's you know
we'll take the family dog let's let's
all get on together and and and go
explore what a wonderful opportunity
that would be for anyone anyone and I
really think that it's in our nature to
explore I did it's in our nature to to
know what's what's over-the-hill what's
what's around the corner what's beyond
our field of view and and I hope we
continue to do that walk out strong a
chip off the old block may I say thank
you very much